des fleurs jetées à la mer c'est
l'hommage qui est rendue suite à la
disparition il y à bien tous ses temps
de l'historien sudel fuma sur les rives
de sainte-suzanne famille ses amis et
les est petit se retrouve face à l'océan
qu'est le 12 juillet 2014
prenez la vie au professeur d'université
spécialiste sur l' esclavage dans
l'océan indien
gardez ça mais moi je trouve que c'est
important parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de
de recherche il a beaucoup sur notre
identité parler des escales c'était
aussi parlé de de cette partie de
l'histoire qui en a beaucoup qui ont
vous refuser d'entendre et qui permet de
comprendre aussi notre métissage sudel
fuma était aussi le directeur de
l'unique chaire unesco à l'université de
la réunion
une place qui n'a toujours pas trouvé de
digne successeur après sa disparition
aujourd'hui à travers l'association
historun qu'il avait créé et présidé le
fruit de son travail est valorisée
il est toujours parmi nous et notre rôle
notre devoir c'est toujours de remettre
en valeur cette recherche de ces
recherches qu'il a il a su mettre en
place pour faire profiter un maximum de
réunionnais tout ne doit pas se passer
au sein des universités des grandes
salles et couleurs que dans les grandes
salles etc
il faut aller vers la population ça
c'est le défi que nous nous sommes
donnés pour faire ce travail là une
double exposition sur les grandes fêtes
patrimoniale tamouls et l'histoire de
l'esclavagé à la réunion se tient à la
maison du patrimoine de sainte suzanne
jusqu'à la fin du mois
l'occasion pour les réunionnais de
renouer avec leur culture et leur
histoire